i've enjoyed his work in zero dark 30
kingsman
uh 1917 siriana and so much more and now
we can
all enjoy his work in spectrum's
originals temple which
started becoming available to all of us
uh eager for this man's work it started
just yesterday exclusively
on spectrum on demand the actor mark
strong here on the rich eisen show how
are you mark
i'm really well thanks rich and uh it's
really great to be talking to you i
really appreciate it where where
am i talking to you from where have i
found you uh amidst this
crazy world in october of 2020 where are
you right now
right now i'm up in my attic office in
london i've just been filming
um temple season two funnily enough we
had a filming day today
and a very heavy scene so i've literally
come straight from there
straight to the phone straight to talk
to you well i greatly appreciate that
when you say heavy what do you mean by
heavy scene mark
it was the end of an episode scene and
and what happens is
uh without wanting to give too much away
somebody gets trapped in a room and in
trying to shoot their way out they
uh unfortunately get hit with the
ricochet
of their own bullet and uh i come upon
the scene
and find um something that i'm
i desperately don't need to find in that
moment so heavy in the sense that it's a
really portentous moment right
at the end of an episode okay so what
would you say where does temple rank for
you
in terms of heavy you've been in a lot
of heavy stuff i mean i just mentioned
against siriana 1917
zero dark 30 for instance even you know
some of the sherlock holmes
stuff you play pretty nasty individual
where does temple rank for you
mark strong
it ranks right up there i have to say i
mean you call those guys bad guys i
i think they're just misunderstood yeah
i like it i like it a lot that's great
yeah i think um you know what's
interesting about characters like that
is is
how conflicted they are i think first of
all we get a kind of visceral pleasure
don't we from kind of indulging
maybe our bad side and sometimes we get
to play it out through characters that
we see
on the screen and on the stage so i kind
of enjoy doing that i also feel like
it's
it's quite far removed from me you know
obviously i don't go around in my daily
life being a bad guy i think i'm a
relatively nice guy to be honest but um
it's kind of cathartic to be able to
play those roles on screen but
the thing about them all is even if
they're kind of not liked
if i can make them at least understood
then i feel like i'm shining a light
on a type of character which is the sort
of person i'm most interested in which
is
a combination of good and bad you know
very conflicted so then who's the most
misunderstood character you've ever
played mark strong
who's the most misunderstood then well
you should say that i think it probably
is daniel milton right now in temple
which is why i gravitated to this this
um
series because basically he makes a lot
of uh
very dubious choices he's a surgeon he's
living a very comfortable life
he's a very happy family man but his
wife
falls sick and in an attempt to save her
life
he basically finds himself in a
situation where he has to make some very
odd moral and ethical choices
in order to save her life so he's doing
things that
might you know alienate um an
ordinary person's sense of what's right
but he's doing it for love so i think
that that is as conflicted as you can
get
and then you know obviously uh opening
in an illegal medical clinic
uh in the uh in the tube um
temple subway station if you will in
london um
it's not it's not like a meth lab or
anything like that but it does sound
like breaking bad where
walter white had to make some serious
decisions about
uh moral decisions about what he needs
to do and he did it out of affection for
his family to try and leave them a
better life
it seems like there might be some sort
of through lines that we're talking
about right here
mark would you agree there is certainly
a similarity in that sense but i think
what
what happens to walter white is he
actually begins to enjoy
his journey over to the dark side i
think the principal difference here with
daniel milton
is that he is dragged kicking and
screaming down a path he doesn't want to
go down
but because he has to make choices at
every turn
in the moment he does the thing that he
thinks is for the best
but actually ends up kind of taking a
few twists and turns
down a path which leads him to a side
that he's not happy
um indulging if you like
so i think he's he's not uh he doesn't
enjoy breaking bad
he's kind of forced to do things that um
that are just a little bit uh a little
bit dodgy that end up you know
with him crossing the rubicon if you
like but like i say
it's all for love so i feel like on some
level an audience might be able to go
with him and his choices
i've got mark strong talking about his
new show temple which is again
started on demand on spectrum just this
very past day joining me here on the
rich eisen show
um which sport do you enjoy following
are you uh
are you a premier league do you like any
particular football team
uh over any other what about your
routing interests
mark do you have one oh yeah i mean it's
funny you should say that i am a very
big
arsenal fan arsenal are you know
premier league soccer team i was born in
islington in north london which is where
highbury the stadium uh uh we used to be
and i think when you grow up in the part
of the world that i did you
you had to make a choice about whether
or not you were going to be involved
with the football and i've been a
lifelong fan i've been a season ticket
holder for the last 20 years
um and i i um
you know i'm not a rabid fan but i i
follow their fortunes and i have to say
if we win
on a weekend i feel pretty good and if
we lose then i just need a day of being
grumpy to get over it
that makes sense i i totally understand
the feeling it's it's it's interesting
mark cause i you know called an american
football game an nfl game
um in the new tottenham stadium and
um oh yeah and yeah and the reason why i
bring it up is the tampa bay buccaneers
are one of the teams that came in
um and was told that the fact that tampa
bay's
red colors were all over tottenham
stadium was a
to the delight of the arsenal fans that
their colors were inside
tottenham stadium and i i kind of got a
kick out of that
mark you know yeah well tottenham are
the big
are the big arsenal rivals the arsenal
tottenham rivalry is a very big london
rivalry that goes
all the way back to the 30s actually not
a lot of people know where maybe that
rivalry comes from but basically it was
because arsenal were originally
a south london team they grew up uh
i'm sorry they were formed
[Music]
and originally called woolwich arsenal
and they were based around
the munitions workers who worked in
south london and tottenham
is an area in north london just
kind of east of highbury and what
happened in the 30s was
the manager at the time managed to
effect a move so the stadium and the
team and the fan base moved from south
london up to north london and tottenham
always felt
that they were invading their territory
unfortunately that season tottenham went
down
we stayed up and i think we've been the
most successful team
ever since much to the annoyance of the
tottenham fans although having said that
the last few years
they've been doing really well and now i
think now with our new manager
arteta we're we're running neck and neck
with them again well i think you might
enjoy this story too mark strong here on
the rich eisen show is that
um the owner of the arsenal uh your
football club is stan
kroenke who owns the los angeles rams
here in the national football league and
i mentioned
two members of the rams organization how
amazing the new tottenham stadium was
and how the rams should play
a game there in the new tottenham
stadium and i was told essentially over
his dead body
that they will never do that because of
arsenal
i don't that is what i was talking about
josh
um own the team and uh
you know they've uh he's called silent
stan i don't think he gets involved that
much with the team but he has recently
just i think
enabled us to buy a player um from
atletico madrid who's come into our
midfield
that might be the answer to our problems
this season so
i know that he's kind of as silent as he
may be
i think he's just uh behind the scenes
been pulling some strings to enable us
to maybe have a good season this season
because we've been struggling a bit the
last few years
um so our fingers are crossed for this
season and we're hoping to get back into
the top four
which gives us a champions league place
and that's what we're
aiming for this season i'll tell you
what um i i think we can both agree
uh stan kroenke's bank account is
anything but silent so
i think that that that is definitely
speaks loudly
um you know so clearly it has for you
yeah he's not short of a few pennies
old stan no not at all you know we're
we're on the peacock uh nbc sports on uh
on uh on peacock channel peacock here in
the united states has a ton of premier
league action so i'd love to get you
back on
uh when things begin to get cooking on
that front i'd love to chat with you on
that
i would love that i mean we're just at
the beginning of our season and uh we're
having kind of a crazy season i have to
say and i don't know if it's because of
the lockdown and all of that
but suddenly a lot of the games are not
going the way that they normally do
and we're having kind of loads of games
in which there's huge goal scores which
doesn't normally happen i always felt
that perhaps
in america way back you know 20 30 40
years ago soccer wasn't popular because
there were too many one nil one one type
score lines but at the moment we're
having like five nil
six one four one you know there's some
great score lines going on and
something's happening this season
so it'd be great to get together and
chat maybe towards the end to see
what madness has happened i love it and
it's interesting because
we're beginning to get used to not
having any fans in the stands watching
the nfl
obviously you've already been through
that and um and maybe
maybe it's just some some players are
beginning to get comfortable
and um and how does that feel uh how
does that feel rich do you think
that the game is changing because there
aren't any fans in the state well i
definitely think that there are as i'm
sure
the same for in premier league for sure
that there are some stadiums where it is
far
easier for the away team to stroll into
and come up with the win
when there aren't crazy fans you know
there's no chanting really in nfl
stands but i think that that is no
question
something that um we're still getting
used to
here yeah i think you're right i think
part of the reason that these games are
becoming really interesting is because
the pressure of the fans
is not there i mean obviously if you're
in a home game
you want your supporters to be helping
your team to victory but obviously going
away
is often really heartbreaking because
you know that you're not there to
support them but
this level playing field where playing
at home doesn't have the advantage that
it used to have
is making things really interesting and
i do remember actually when i was
filming
over in the um i did a play on broadway
and i went to see
the new york giants versus the san
francisco 49ers
and the thing that i remember most of
all was the movement of the fans because
when you go to a soccer game
in the uk everybody tends to sit quite
close together
every seat is full and you're
concentrating on the game
nobody leaves their feet whereas
i remember at the nfl game people were
in and out they were calling out to each
other they were going
off to get a drink they were going off
to get some food the same was true
when i went to see when i was filming in
detroit and i went to see the tigers
play baseball
i couldn't believe it it was like a sort
of medieval market with people running
around
selling hot dogs and beer and in fact
there was one famous guy who kind of
almost sang opera and he was selling his
hot dogs with this kind of hard dogs
kind of
song that he used to do and i always
used to wonder whether the players on
the pitch could hear him and whether it
put them off
so now i wonder what it must be like to
play when there's no fans at all
oh my gosh there are a couple of venues
where
fans are allowed in and the i've spoken
to players they hear every word that's
being said in their direction
every last really oh yeah it can get
particularly
you can't have any thin skin let's put
it that way you know when you're hearing
the knobs they're quite they're being i
don't know if you ever watch a premier
league game you know you sometimes see
when a player
goes to take a corner or a throw in at
the side of the pitch you can sometimes
see the fans just behind them and if
it's the wrong fans
it sometimes gets a little embarrassing
because they get very very vocal
i bet mark i really appreciate the uh
the call
and the time uh before i let you go i i
do have a question i know you
were only in it for a brief bit what was
it like shooting 1917
what was that like uh knowing that
obviously
um you know i i'm sure that there were
certain camera tricks
uh unless it was one whole long
scene that you had to get right uh what
was that like
for you mark it was it was a revelation
i have to say it was very unlike the
normal process of filming because
i had two sequences in the film and i
shot those
on two separate days a month apart
and every sequence in the film was shot
as a continuous sequence
so there are a number of edits in the
film obviously the whole thing couldn't
be shot in one but there are a number of
edits
but the kind of trickery of modern
cinema means
it's virtually seamless um but it meant
that i turned up
we rehearsed my scene we did it a few
times
then we shot it a few times and
basically once we had it in the can
then that was it there was no lens
changing there was no
close-ups there was no changing of
camera angles or anything it was just
that one thing
and i remember kind of um feeling like
it was a much quicker process than you
normally have on a movie
and i wondered whether it would work but
when i saw the film
i have to say it it blew me away i just
thought the immediacy of the
feeling that it's one single shot gives
you a real sense of what it might have
been like to be there
it really was mark uh that that that
film
was to me uh i thought it was
a best picture i i really did and and
and it blew me
totally away and um left me
wanting more to be honest with you which
is crazy because it was so harrowing
i wanted to kind of put it aside yeah
you know and and i just wanted to ask
you about
because i'm such a you know an
aficionado of the way
films are made and it seemed to me so
special i was just wondering what it
was like to act in it
well it was a little like doing a series
of mini plays because obviously normally
you have scenes
in a normal film or television show that
are
you know a couple of pages long whereas
this would be five or six pages
so you'd be doing you know six seven
eight
minute sequences and basically if you
come from the theater which i did and
most of the actors in that film did
it really isn't it isn't that difficult
to play those as continuous scenes
what it did mean however if for example
like in one of the scenes i did there
were a bunch of guys
moving a tree in the background if one
of those guys fell over
or dropped a rifle or you know perhaps
the truck that we got into didn't start
then we had to start the whole sequence
again from the beginning
and i remember andrew scott who's a
lovely actor has a sequence where he has
to
i think he has to open a letter read a
letter and at the same time he has to
light a cigarette
and he had to do something like 40 takes
because the lighter you know he'd get to
the point where he had to light the
cigarette and it wouldn't the lighter
wouldn't work
so um you had to have a lot of patience
doing it
but once you got the scene shot uh
yeah it was like doing a series of mini
plays
mark it's been a a terrific conversation
i appreciate the time i'm a fan of your
work
um check out temple the eight part
series is available
now exclusively on spectrum on demand
and speaking of uh medieval circus that
he mentioned uh
one of the uh co-stars is uh charisse
van outen who is
melisandre from uh game of thrones so
there's a fascinating cast and a great
show and i look forward to seeing more
in
our next chat mark thanks for the time
that's really kind of you rich thanks so
much appreciate it that's mark strong
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here